i mean this is the uh
quintessential is there gonna be another
dreamville compilation question
that'll be smart yeah you know what i'm
saying that'll be smart to do that the
last one was so epic and if we brought
it in hone it anymore just about making
more so about the uh the collective you
know what i'm saying because there's a
lot of outside yeah we just a couple
features in there just making it by the
collective it'd be way it was so good
though man it was really good
i told eve i was like bro the fact that
you because i know that y'all pulled
from he pulled from so many records
and i was like bro the fact you're able
to pull from so many different joints
and make
like
i'm sure a scattered creative process
sounds so cohesive yeah so many
different
artists thing
album rapping
he was on the album rapping what yeah
don't forget i said that just listen for
you sound like mf doom on god
you got ibrahim
rapping is boss on the song too
you doing like uh you got boss on the
album right yeah you don't like
backgrounds and you know what i'm saying
yeah i love boss now that he's like kind
of in this like melodic bag that's where
yeah like he killed the coal album facts
facts i love his parts on there yeah
when i was like i was like who the [ __ ]
is this i said
i'm like you got a new pocket what yeah
boss